Bruce Pascoe covers Arizona basketball
for the Arizona Daily Star in Tucson
comm and he joins us now
Bruce bring us up to speed where do we
stand with the local reaction to
Miller's do not meal yesterday it's a
mix I mean I think most of the fans here
are pretty excited they think things are
back to normal but I think there's also
a faction that thinks that this is sort
of a temporary injunction and you know
they're still going more going on behind
the scenes that I was of right now
there's no reason that the university
felt there was no reason to fire him or
were suspend him so he's back and you
know we just don't know what's gonna go
on after this either with this thing or
of course the whole federal
investigation that's already have one
assistant coach arrested and fired well
I think that's where I have I still have
dealt with this and I've been through
this you know over three decades where
somebody tells you something and it's
hey I'm gonna believe you and we've had
everybody from Lance Armstrong you know
you go down the Rafael Palmero under
oath you're never quite sure but it
feels like there's still smoke going on
somewhere there's a fire maybe in the
program and I don't know if Shawn Miller
is attached to it there's no head coach
that I can remember ever hearing who
would be involved in the direct payment
to a player it doesn't make any sense
whatsoever Bruce right right well we
were surprised I mean I think there's a
surprise about that if that happened but
you know and the other thing is now
they've the answer the blade has changed
the rules where you can't have that
plausible deniability and if things go
on and if it's if these things that
happen in the federal investigation
it does what they found translated into
violations by the assistant coach Shawn
Noah is still on the hook for that under
the current rules unless he proves he
can
he totally vetted him every day and
monitored his compliance which is very
hard to prove so either way there could
really be you know something down the
road maybe it's just a suspension or
something but you know it's it's it's
hard to say they're completely in the
clear until you know certainly from what
it seems like right now all right but
it's ESPN doubled down
on this what's your reaction to ESPN
sticking behind their reporter on this
well you know it's I mean it's it's not
our story and and every indication is if
they are if they are doing that and
they've done it not not in a number of
ways they've changed the I think the
only thing that they've admitted you
know was off was the timeline a little
bit on when this call actually happened
and if it was a phone call about DeAndre
and the timeline of 2017 is a little bit
odd because DeAndre Aiden committed in
September 2016 however you know that's
possible that you know a discussion was
made at any time about about anything
that's really the issue is you know was
there a discussion or not and it the
timeline is is kind of secondary as far
as what's important is you know what
could be an issue here and then Jack
Sundy committed in is now committing to
UCLA is there is there any thought of or
any chance of getting him back if Sean
Miller is exonerated here you know I I
don't think so but it's possible but it
is interesting I looked at his he posted
on Twitter last night something about
lol what the Arizona fans who were you
know who were negative at him and I
think there's already some split there
I never thought his commitment was as
solid as you know some you see with with
player so and you know from everything
I've heard about him I think he wants to
stay really close to home he's from LA
so yeah I don't see that but you know
Miller is resourceful enough recruiter
that that if he does stick around you
know he'll be able to probably be able
to scrape together something this year
and get by he's got one commit left for
2018 as right now and that's Brandon
Williams up by star point guard in LA
he's who's pretty good but obviously
he's gonna need a lot more than that
because he could lose a lot this year
regardless of what happens with with his
own personal situation Bruce I know
you're busy we appreciate your time
thanks for joining us good luck alright
thank you that's Bruce Pasco he covers
Arizona basketball for the Arizona Daily
Star in Tucson dot-com for more Dan
Patrick show to the
it's channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]